don't mind me I'm literally a one-woman
show hello everyone its Alicia Malone
back with another episode of fandango
indie movie Guide this week I am at
Fantastic Fest
and all these people behind me you're
probably wondering what the hell I'm
doing sticking a camera in my face but I
wanted to show you this Film Festival
because it has to be one of the most fun
festivals of the year held each year
here in Austin Texas the thing that
makes this festival so much fun is the
choice of movies it's also really fun
because they have great events so last
night I went to the fantastic debates
and that's where you get to people in
the ring first they debate the topic
with words and then they debate with
their fists so one of the film's playing
here at Fantastic Fest is called
American honey and I was lucky enough to
see this movie in camp it's like a
lyrical slice-of-life drama
it doesn't really follow a structured
narrative it's about a young girl played
by newcomer sasha lane it was literally
found on the beach sunbaking and put in
this movie this is business opportunity
we go door to door we saw magazines we
explore like America we party going to
be big she has something about her that
is so fascinating so great to watch on
screen it is quite long so some people
may struggle with the length it's two
hours 45 minutes I have to say it's
r-rated there are some explicit scenes
although it's fascinating to see sex
scenes done by a female director Andrea
Arnold and the whole thing is a look at
these group of people who you might not
necessarily look at both on screen and
off I thought it was beautiful the
soundtrack was wonderful I loved it I
say give it a go scared bank while here
at Fantastic Fest I got to sit down with
the wonderful Sasha Lane I tried to make
her my best friend I tried to interview
her and I tried to film the whole
interview myself so I forgive me if it
doesn't look as professional as normal
but I started out asking Sasha how she
would describe this movie I think it's
finding yourself I think it's like love
I think it's like craziness I think it's
music and how that interplay keno goes
into life and modes and some people have
said that they wanted to you know stay
after they like talk to us but have
taken it so personal that they had to go
home or that it just really hit them and
all of that I think it's beautiful
even the ones you know if face like
hated it I'm like oh such passion cool
like you know if you're in the mood for
other great films directed by women
there are three fantastic movies that
came out quite recently that you can
watch at home on Fandango now the first
one is called girlhood it's a French
movie it was going to be the second one
I would suggest is the Diary of a
teenage girl that's an indie gem like to
print that yesterday ok and the third
one is the touching sweet funny
infinitely polar bear why do you know so
much
so another film that's in cinemas this
week that I wanted to talk to you about
is called denial
why do you continually denigrate the
work of David Irving you can have
opinions about the Holocaust but I won't
meet with anyone who says the Holocaust
didn't happen as it is that
I am that David early I think just sent
us notice of a suit to be filed in the
High Court the thing is to prove her
case she actually had to prove that the
Holocaust existed that it actually
happened and come up with some hard
evidence to support that and that's
quite a tough task because the Nazis
didn't exactly keep a lot of records
afterward there are no hope in that
group therefore there never were any
jeniboots
this is a fantastic courtroom drama
everyone was talking about this as a
Toronto International Film Festival it's
all held together by a compelling
performance by Rachel vice Timothy Spall
is her opponent and he is creepy I think
it's worth a watch particularly if you
love plays or movies that feel like play
I'm not attacking freedom of speech I've
been defending my right to stand up
against someone who wants to cover the
truth
so just to recap if you're up for
something experimental check out
American honey in theaters if you're up
for something that's a little more
standard with fantastic performances
then check out denial and as always let
me know in the comments below which
movies you'd like to watch which movies
you've seen lately that you've enjoyed
emulation Malone I'll check to you next
week